we're the coolest kids at preschool
[Music]
I have never done this before I'm very
afraid of just dying
I've been hailed other things before
let's just say that what never Helion
are you ready let's hear it
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Oh God it's so weird but I still
kind of felt like I sound in real life
testing no it doesn't sound different do
you think this is what astronauts sound
like if they were to open their helmets
in space I think I'd just die I like
tile cake this better wow you did it
yeah I feel so proud of myself do you
work at Starbucks cuz I like you a latte
I really would love to have a puppy my
puds name would be jeffrey jackson
nickels cuz that's my list
what's your opinion on pizza because I
love pizza I love pepperoni pizza and
sausage pizza is as is full oh there it
is I thought I loved it
okay I'm I'm saying I feel like this is
what I'm supposed to sound like in real
life I feel like I still have a nasally
voice I think maybe you're just
realizing what you sound like when I
real in real life maybe I love this I
love helium this is like a fun safe way
if you just experience a different side
of yourself sucking helium is a lot like
smoking pot you have to hold it in your
lungs which explains why it wasn't
working the first time and also why I've
never been high Jeffery Jackson nickels
that sounds like presidential he could
be like the next presidential don't know
well let's wait to like 2020 deserves a
good home and a good father this is so
great can I take some of this to go
[Music]